[Music]  most cathedrals have been built to  withstand the test of time  but not this one  welcome to the easter arches of sicily  italy  but come quick they won't last  [Music]  every easter the town of san biago in  sicily italy is home to a cathedral made  out of breads cereals and pastas  visitors are able to wander through the  arches of bread and enjoy the detailed  designs up close  the structure is created by locals and  takes around three months to construct  [Music]  the origins of this tradition date back  to ancient times when visiting royals  expected to be greeted with grand  displays  san biago was a town of mostly poor  farmers so they used what they had  bread  in the mid-18th century the tradition  became a celebration of easter  although the appetizing displays aren't  edible a walk through the arches of  bread is a testament to the city's long  history and the artistic capabilities of  its citizens  [Music]  you